ich weiß zwei drei dinge über meine
kindheit meine mutter und ich kam aus
dem iran
aber lebten allein in deutschland
[Musik]
ich hatte auch ein vater aber damals
wusste ich nicht warum wir nicht sehr
nachdenklich machen da und sehr
eindrucksvoller film meine mutter und
ich verstehen uns sehr gut und trotzdem
können wir einfach nicht über die
vergangenheit sprechen über 30 jahre
schweigen und kein einziges mal habe ich
sie gefragt mama was ist uns im
gefängnis passiert und die in diesem
film den umständen ihrer geburt nachgeht
geboren in einem gefängnis in das ist
heute noch ein gefängnis für
regime-gegner die dort gefangen gehalten
und auch gefoltert werden
sie hatte sich zuerst überlegt diesen
film auch zu machen ohne sich selbst
daran zu zeigen und hat dann aber
festgestellt das funktioniert nicht sie
muss selbst auftreten weil sie ihre
eigene geschichte herausfinden
das geht schlecht wenn man sich selbst
aus dem bild nimmt und deshalb sehen wir
sie über jahre wie sie versucht erstens
mit ihrer mutter ins gespräch darüber zu
kommen was da geschehen ist das feld
ihrer mutter aber sehr schwer also sie
kann an sich dieses gespräch nicht
führen
und deshalb sucht sie dann andere zeugen
auf also menschen die auch im gefängnis
waren oder kinder von menschen die auch
dort im gefängnis waren in den 80er
jahren und das erweist sich als sehr
sehr schwierig diese spurensuche erweist
sich als sehr schwierig weil das alles
offenbar so traumatisch und so
schrecklich ist was da passiert ist für
viele menschen dass sie einfach das
gespräch darüber nicht führen können
das ist zu schwer und gegen diese
widerstände anzugehen oder zu sehen
welche fragen sind überhaupt möglich und
welche antworten bekommt man in welche
antworten bekommt man vielleicht auch
nicht darum geht es in velen man wohl
damit zu verhindern und jonah lomu
nature hast dann kam und warum
oder schon kennt man meist politisch
sehr aktuell deshalb weil dieses
gefängnis immer noch ein politisches
gefängnis ist im moment ist im ewigen
gefängnis zum beispiel in der
inhaftierte nasrin sotudeh das ist eine
menschenrechtsanwältin die sich für die
belange von frauen in iran einsetzt und
die dort jetzt wieder inhaftiert ist war
schon mal frei gekommen jetzt ist wieder
inhaftiert 33 jahre haft 148 stock oder
peitschen liebe das sind so die strafen
dorf erzogen werden also das ist ein
sehr aktueller film vor diesem
hintergrund wollen eving ist eigentlich
auch ein familienfilm mit zwei jahren
kamen kamen sie mit aus dem gefängnis
raus und ihre mutter auch beide sind
dann nach deutschland gekommen konnten
hierhin viel später kam der vater nach
deprimierend ist der film eigentlich
nicht er ist sehr ernst er ist aber auch
sehr lustig denn es gibt ganz viele
komische momente es gibt nach richtig
machen die momente es gibt momente in
dem es nicht weiter geht dann gibt es
welche die wirklich sehr berührend sind
also der film ist eigentlich für jeden
geeignet man muss jetzt sich nicht
unbedingt für außenpolitik interessieren
oder für flüchtlings thematik sondern
uns eigentlich nur ein mensch sein denn
darum geht dass es geht darum was es
bedeutet ein mensch zu sein es geht
darum was es bedeutet sich mit schweren
sachen in der eigenen biografie
auseinanderzusetzen oder auch zu fragen
was die eltern erlebt haben und das sind
eigentlich so universelle geschichte der
iran ist da jetzt halt diese persönliche
komponente aber das lässt sich
übertragen auf alles mögliche
insofern ist der film für jeden zu
empfehlen du packst du die courage
fossil aus
christoph
songs wie it's not least super tonis tor
[Applaus]
[Musik]